Who was your grade? Because I had
Tyson to there, you know, he was,
he became one of them.
And um,
I remember it was funny because when
I would put it down, like I said,
everyone lied about to experience, but
you know, they lied about everything.
But I would put down, uh, you know,
the, the age and everything else,
all the stuff for what it was worth,
you had to have something
to try to believe in, right.
And then figure it out from there.
So Tyson, when I first had him,
he was 190 pounds, not a bum. Also 12
years old. Okay. That's what it was.
But that's what he was. I
mean, that's what God made
it so crazy. So I go down in,
I put the first fight. Nobody's seen
Tyson, nobody's ever seen tight.
But at 12 years old,
zero five. Okay. Hello
Daddy. Now you go too far.
You like more than us.
You learn a lot from us. I said, thanks.
That's a compliment. I said, I think
that Nelson, that's a compliment. I mean,
I'd take a dyke as it is, right,
right. I'm not lying. 12 years old,
190 pounds, please, please, please. Now.
So I'm going to learning, okay. He's
12 years old. It's going to be 13 soon,
but he's technically, he's 12
years older. Gay. Oh, come on.
I said, all right, I'll
make you feel better.
I'll put down 70 [inaudible] now
you tell the truth. I think that 17,
but I knew what I had and know
like cost side, I knew what I had.
So I fought a 17 year old.
I wasn't going to find no 12 year old.
That wasn't going to happen. Right. And
plus I get arrested for murder. So, oh,
what was he like at 12 years old?
Physically, mentally weak, but physically,
what do I mean? Mentally weak. Not Weak
for the average guy, but before fighter.
Um,
okay.
He's still have remanence
he still had residual,
okay.
Stuff from his upbringing. Listen,
you are, know the truth about the guy.
I mean he oldest,
but he used to hide in between abandoned
building walls in Brownsville is a
rough place. No doubt about
it. Didn't have a father,
whatever, the mother, whatever.
And, uh, he,
he used to hide between
walls to not get picked on.
And I believe when you do that,
you never get outside of that
wall to a certain extent.
You're always hide in a wall for the rest
of your life as this is my belief that
teddy, what are you talking about?
It became heavyweight champ.
Some people think it's the greatest.
I'll bet
I don't have his record in front of me.
And this is going to blow some people
crazy, but what are you going to do?
I don't have his record.
Let's just say we're going to make an
arbitrary number because your man's going
to pull it up.
But let's just say it's 50 and six.
I would say five 15 five but whatever.
I think his record is truly,
if you're going to be this,
and we're not truly in life with anything,
but if we're truly,
truly in an absolute world,
which we don't live in,
but I would say he's all in five high now.
Everybody says everyone who is
listening to you think he's just like,
let me get with Teddy's drinking. Like,
I don't see them drinking nothing,
but he probably had some
before he came in. To me,
a fight is not a fight into
this resistance to, there's
something to overcome,
something to overcome.
Otherwise it's just an athletic venture.
It's an exhibition.
I think life is that.
I think the, you don't know of a
lawyer is a lawyer into, into the some,
the overcoming the courtroom. Something
goes for, okay. I know he's a lawyer.
I know he went to, I get it. Nobody has
to tell me that, but he ain't a lawyer.
He Ain't dad until everything goes wrong.
The judge droves all this crap out and,
and he's,
he is aft,
so to speak and,
and he figured and he's still handles it.
Then he's a lawyer.
A doctor is not adopting to,
he opens up this kid,
a kid just like he's got it home and
arteries are bleeding all over the place
and it's not in a textbook.
It's not in a fricken textbook.
And he got to do it.
He got to figure it out and he got,
then he's a doctor then he's
a surgeon at that level. You,
you're not, you are not in a fight. I,
I, look, I admit it. I
equate life to a fight. I do.
You're not in a fight.
And so there's pressure
resistance overcoming something.
Otherwise it's just an exhibition.
Tyson's talent was so great.
His physical ability,
his talent was so overwhelming.
Just like somebody
intellect to some bodies,
charisma,
whatever beauty until it
came to something else.
But his talent was so superior that
the other stuff never got tested.
He was blown guys out and
he had never got tested.
If there was anything in the warehouse,
so to speak,
is there anything inside you never knew?
And then five times,
whatever the real record is,
five times there was resistance.
Five times it became a real fight.
Five Times.
There was something to overcome
and he fell in all five times.
He was only in firefights in his
life and his own five, I'm sorry,
sal graves, because we know my
history with them. Right. Am I in my,
am I capable of didactic Newman?
Yeah. But I can honestly tell you
that I, I, I took, um,
I try to be better than
that, that, that I've,
I've called many fights where the people
in the call and I couldn't stand them.
I had no respect for them.
But if they,
if they did a good drop in a
corner of their Friday did job,
I talked to about them,
like they were Ray Arcel like they were
Angelo Dundee because that's what it was
supposed to be. That's all. And
it's selfish because I don't want,
I wanna have,
I wanna know and I want my kids to know
that I can be better than that. That,
that it's,
it's about,
it's about the code of the profession.
It's a, it's about you. It's about,
you believe in that.
Would you say is,
should be honest. It should be what you
believe. It shouldn't be tainted or, or,
or influenced by lesser things that,
that it does represent you.
It does represent your family.
It does represent where you came from.
It does stay.
Do you know your blurted out for those
five minutes or maybe two hours on ESPN,
but it stays,
someone can go back to it.
You could go back to it. How do you
feel about it? It does mean something.
It really does it.
And so I'm only saying it because I
would say it about somebody else in a way
that I calibrate things.
The way that I evaluate things that I
don't think that you know crap about
somebody until they're tested.
You don't know the friend,
you don't know if they're good wife. You
don't know if they're a good girlfriend,
you don't know crap you think you'd do,
but until they're really tested,
you don't really know. And Tyson, when he
got tested, when he had to overcome some,
when,
when he didn't run him over with like,
like one of those big monster trucks
running over Volkswagen because he was a
monster truck pull Volkswagens.
Yeah, he was. Yeah, he was. And was,
he wanted the greatest
punches all day? Yeah. Yes.
Could he punch from either side of the
plate like Mickey Mann or the greatest
switch hitter? Was He that in by?
Yes. Could he could punch evenly.
Great with either hand. For me
side. Was he all those things? Yes.
Was he as great an
intimidators Sonny Liston? Yes.
Was he a great finisher like Joe
Louis? To a certain extent, yes,
but he wasn't a great fighter
because great fighters won.
The fight came to them.
They found a way to do
what they had to do.
He found a way to disappear.
They found a way to show up.
Yeah,
show up.
He found a way to go and
not show up and look.
You could go
talk to psychiatrists and you could go
to for the reasons why the old hiding
between a war when he was a kid.
Yeah. That, that's part of it.
I'll tell you another part of it.
To be that,
not to be the power puncher, not
to be the aggressor, not to be.
Just those things. To be, to
tighten, to be the Viking,
to be the Samurai, to be the
warrior, to be those things.
It has to be inside you.
You have to believe in it all.
A lot of times people lie in life.
This is Fullerton plays, you can't lie.
Okay.
You know, sometimes we'd say that the
ring is a chamber of truth, you know,
it sounds good and all that,
but it does.
It is because just like in
other places in life too,
when the moment comes
for those kinds of serious things,
you have to feel like that.
You say that you're the conqueror,
you Alexander the Great, your all those
things. Right. Okay. Word sounds great.
Makes good soundbites.
Probably bring more people to the TV,
but when the moment comes and you didn't
intimidate a guy that didn't work. Okay.
We all try it to a certain
extent. Right? Probably. Yeah.
I'm sure you've looked at guys certain
ways when you were younger and you'd
purposely looked at them in
a way to invoke a certain
kind of action,
a certain kind of result from them.
Just just look at them in a real serious
way that you hope that we can do. Yeah.
And but because I know your background,
you will prepare to do what came
after that, but some people aren't.
Some people aren't.
And Tyson was in as great as he was.
I just said it.
He's great guys that hate
me for [inaudible] today,
your hero or whatever your favorite guy,
when he's great,
she's not great and in his
area and when that moment comes
you have to,
that's where the truth matters.
You have to believe that you really,
that guy and if your guy that he and he
was convicted so I think it's fair that
rape somebody. Okay now listen, I
wasn't in that room and I don't know,
a lot of people don't take
okay but he was convicted or,
but I know enough people in the business
that there was a lot of other bad
things that he did that it just not things
that that you would probably want to
hang around with somebody if you know,
if you're a halfway decent human being
that he did devil week things. Okay.
Week thing.
So when you do read things and you know
you did though and I don't know what,
but I'm just saying you do week things
and you know they will week things and
now you got to do a strong thing.
How do you become strong when you know
that you did those weak things and you
know that's really you and you got a guy,
a causeway from your name,
Nevada Holyfield that doesn't give
a shit about how hard you punch.
Does it give a crap about
what a finisher does?
It give a crap about how fast you put
your punches together. He wants to find,
you're going to have to make him a
believer by doing it and doing it in a
difficult place because he's gonna make
it difficult because he ain't gonna
cooperate.
When that happens,
you got to feel like that person.
And when you don't feel like that person,
you got a problem.
And as what happened wasn't
a matter when he bit his ear,
it was a matter that he was hungry. It
was a savage and who's was from the suit?
Stop the crap.
It was a way to get out
because he knew he wasn't that guy. And
when you're not that guy, guess what?
You have a great talent off.
Recognize when somebody is
there as your greatest talent.
He can recognize when somebody is,
and he recognized that Evander Holyfield
was and I was his way to get out.
Okay.
And he did. So that's why,
again, it's not sour grapes.
It's really not because I'm more selfish
than that. I really do care about
what my reputation is and whether or not,
uh,
I've been honest about things they say.
It doesn't mean I'm right per means.
I believe it. I do care about that. I do.
Yeah.
And so it's not,
that doesn't mean I'm right,
but it means I have a reason to
believe on right from the way of live,
from what I've seen,
what I've experienced in the business,
the human condition,
how strong it can be and
how we could can be. And,
um, he was his strongest guy,
if you ever going to see,
but he was his weaker person
as you ever going to find.
That's intense.
But I see what you're saying in terms
of you are judging it by the highest
standards possible. You're judging
it in comparison to other champions.
You're judging it. You, you, you, what
else you got to jump through with Joe.
Of course.
Well,
you look at guys who are known for
incredible heart and their ability to come
back like Diego corrals,
David Corral, sin,
some of those wars when you would
say, Whoa, we could steal. Yes.
That was one of the greatest fights
of all time. The forest of credible,
greatest fight of all Micky ward. Arturo.
Gary the first one, right? Not the second,
third, the first, the first HUD
believable. Unbelievable. I mean, no,
if you want to go back,
if you want to go back farther,
lot of people will know this,
but you should call him was involved
in a lot and unfortunately he paid the
price. Okay. Yes. But
Bobby should it in the 70s,
eighties he was involved in those
fights every other day. Yeah, no,
I'm just kidding. But he was invited
to many of those fights. Yeah.
And unfortunately you don't know about
Bobby Chicago and you talk to somebody
again, I'm going to like the baseball
thing. You talk about the average guy,
Bobby Chicago.
Who the hell's that?
Who the hell is an unforeseen, is the
guy that would know his name anymore.
But, uh, he was a pretty special guy
in that ring. He was pretty damn tough.
Tougher than most people.
There's guys that unfortunately
relied on that toughness. Right? Yeah.
Like when you, when it comes to
guys known for incredible Chins,
that can be a detriment. Yes. And
it can be if that's all you have.
Do you think that's what you have?
Cause she used to put it this way cause
she used to that because he wanted me to
be a great trainer. So she used to always
be with me, all the terms, you know,
saying things and costs would say day
two tough guys. Okay, Gotcha.
Now what's tough?
It's a prerequisite to being a fighter.
You better be tough. But what Lovell.
So all levels the greys and I got you.
But how special is being tough?
Because if you're a fighter you should
be tough. I got Ya. Homelessness.
So you got two tough guys,
but one of them is smart.
Taught,
developed.
That's him.
He's tough one now. That's
how he explained the tougher
because he's smart. Yeah.
Tough. Yeah. And smart.
He, he goes from here,
he's here because he's not just
dependent only on toughness.
So He's tougher than this
guy. Right. Cause he don't
have to depend on just that.
Right. You might not even have to
get to it. It's there as a reserve.
It's always there to call on like an
army. You call on, you need it. Right.
But he's not dependent just on that.
Isn't that the balanced though,
is knowing that you have it. Yeah.
Knowing that you have it and it's there.
There it is. See what you just said.
You have to know that you are it.
Tyson didn't know he was it.
We ever met that night.
He probably knocked me and say, does
it whatever. I don't. It's okay.
And so I get I,
it's okay.
Well there's certain people that you
can't question and Aranda Holyfield's one
of those people. That's why that fight
was so fascinating because it was,
Phil was, he is a 100% warrior.
Well, he had to write nickname.
Most of them don't.
Most of them don't have the right
fight nickname and whatever they do.
But the real, the real deal,
he was the real deal. Yeah.
And you know why small heavyweights, you
want to know why? I mean trace it back,
cause always told me this but I
learned it innately on my own too.
But trace it back to the parents,
trace it back to the background.
Tracy trace it back to all that stuff.
Trace it back.
He did. He didn't live up to
something. He didn't face something.
He didn't do whatever was there was about,
he had a mother that he talked
about a few times and I, I'm sorry,
event of, I'm not saying exact
but, but it's, it's there.
Yeah
that and a great model obviously,
but she,
they had, or the grew up in
Georgia tech goes Atlanta pub,
whatever suburb of Georgia and she,
you have definite age, you know,
different time down south and all that.
Had a little,
I guess a little shack in the back
with a thing called twitches switch.
It switches. I'm sorry, I'm twitching
switches.
And
she basically had different size
switches, you know, short ones, long ones,
medium ones depending on the occasion.
And when he didn't live up to what
he had to tell the truth, whatever,
be accountable. Okay.
Face what he had to face,
whatever.
Um,
she had a switch fam and you know what
it um,
informed him cause he faced things.
Tyson, Tyson on the other hand and
listen, did he ask for it and no,
no. He didn't ask for
that opinion. I get it.
But I know people have that upbringing
and they get to a point they can take and
make a left turn instead of a right turn.
Is your ability to make,
don't you think there was also the,
the overwhelming hype and celebrity
involved in Mike Tyson in his prime?
It was probably so difficult for him
to even understand himself. Yeah. But,
but what he did understand,
and I'm glad you said that.
Okay.
Right backwards.
What he did and what he did understand
was there was a way out of Anda learn.
There was no way out,
you know, oppose away. You
know what I mean? Right. Yeah.
Like somebody would come and pay.
Yeah.
And he did a lot of things before he
became champion and somebody was always
there with a check or cash or whatever.
And, and w would absolve them from,
it would, would not have to face
what he did. Right. And, and,
but there was a switch that Amanda hat
of his face and that's what made him what
made him, and that's what allowed Tyson
part of would move out. Tyson, you look,
you make your own choice
at a certain point life.
So there's not make too many excuses,
but it is part of it that,
that he was formed by what he was
allowed to do when he shouldn't have been
allowed to do those things.
And that was one of the issues that
you had with costs, right? Yeah.
That you felt like costs was ignoring
his own principles and teaching because
this guy was so special.
Yeah.
And cause he was getting older and because
recognize you didn't have much time
left in this guy had a legitimate shot
at being a world champion for cause heavy
thing in his, you know, everything in the
world of boxing success and everything.
He was great.
He was special because his whole life he
didn't get married for a reason because
he was married to box.
And as he said that it wouldn't been fair.
I mean this was a different guy that it
was boxing his whole everything life was
boxing and lessons were
connected to boxing,
everything and um,
principals boxing and uh,
so there's uh, you know, there's
a guy that his whole, you know,
you used that word legacy,
but really his whole existence was boxing.
And for him it was heavyweight champs.
He had Floyd Patterson,
youngest heavyweight champ ever.
That was cost.
That was because it was about
lightweights. Listen, he had lightweights.
He had welterweights Jose Torres. Yeah,
Jose towards light heavyweight champion.
Exactly right.
He had other guys too.
But it was the heavyweight champion of
the world because it was around where we
talked about before when
box was the biggest sport,
bigger than baseball and it
was the heavyweight champ
of the world was Babe Ruth.
It was rocky Marciano and that,
and you're going to say that before you
leave this earth that you have a chance
to have another heavyweight
champ to might be the best,
could be one of the best ever and
could break Patterson's record,
which was part of the plan, part
of the plan. When costs was alive,
you're going to break Patterson's reg.
He broke it.
He became the youngest
heavyweight champion.
And so when you float that
out there w if you will, and,
and tempt the guy with that,
even a great guy like cause some things
are going to be pushed to the side and
he did. Yeah, compromised and he did.
Do you think if he didn't do that,
the Tyson would have
been a different person?
I'm going to use his words there
was told to me by a great promoter.
Mickey thought he passed away.
He was close to Jim Jacobs who was close
to cause and he was up there sometimes
we have to.
I left and all that and Mickey wanted me
to train all those fighters and he was
a great promoter. Mickey, he had great
sayings. He was a very witty guy,
but he was a sharp guy.
Boxing was his life too.
And he ran everything in
London with three partners.
One of them was Java to stay who owned
Wembley Stadium. So they were powerful.
They ran everything.
They were the cartel in
London back in those days.
He told me that performed cost died that
cause had said some nice things about
teddy atlas,
but he said and loads,
I know there's a danger that this can
be convenient. You know what I mean?
Self serving crap.
Sometimes you got to trust whatever.
I was told by Mickey that he said that
Teddy Atlas was right but was wrong,
was who's going to get in the way of the
possibility of making a great fighter.
Um,
if he did things his way as far as the
disciplining in the in or whatever.
Um, eve, in other words, whether he
left it like that, so I don't know.
So I know what I think it meant that
title wouldn't have been around if you did
it, if you're disciplined, that he
would have laughed. I don't know,
cause I don't know that he had those
options because he was a ward of the state
and uh,
you know,
it was coming out of obviously a
criminal situation who's coming out of a
juvenile detention center
called Trion up outside of old,
30 miles outside of Albany. Um, you
know, so I don't know that he had,
but basically that if teddy
did it his way, he was right,
but he was wrong because it would have
ruined the possibility of a great fighter
and I could let that happen.
So I don't think that it's,
I don't know if it's true,
actually. I don't know.
You know what I was about to say?
I don't think that's true
because of course it's me. Right?
I want to make myself feel good.
So I want to say you could add
the best of both worlds. So good.
We had maybe a better person or within
the realm of a better person. Right.
Boundaries. Right. There
were no boundaries.
Maybe they would have those boundaries
would have made a difference. Right.
And you still would have had the town.
It was so absent.
The talent wasn't going to dissipate
because I have to discipline, you know,
that you put on them as a human being.
That wasn't going to change.
But because, because we're saying
that it wasn't gonna happen.
Maybe you'll lose them.
Maybe it goes to someone else at a
certain point in his development.
Maybe that's what he meant.
I Dunno.